[Music]
on this sunday night did canadians heed
warnings to stay
home for the holidays were the lockdown
measures enough to curb the rise in
covid cases
the next week will be will tell us and
what will be the full
impact of christmas and new year's
growing calls for ontario to ramp up
protection for long-term care residents
i didn't know how bad it was until
actually
being in it
global national with robin gill
reporting tonight
colleen christie good evening thanks for
joining us
the holiday period is coming to an end
and health officials across the country
are bracing for a possible spike in
covet 19 cases
today quebec released its first numbers
of the year and they're grim
the province recorded more than 7 600
new cases since new year's eve
nearly 2 900 of them were recorded in
the last
24 hours a new single day record
ontario's numbers are still the highest
in the country with close to 3
000 new cases despite strict rules over
the holiday period in many parts of the
country
health experts are worried many
canadians may not have listened
mike armstrong has our top story tonight
downtown montreal in lockdown the city's
core deserted
in what will be a decisive week quebec's
new kovit 19 numbers released sunday
are among the worst since the pandemic
started an average of 2 500 new cases
over three days but despite that they're
not quite as bad as many
expected doctor gerber boucher is ahead
of quebec's association of emergency
medicine specialists
i guess it's good in the sense it's not
going up but it's bad in the sense that
it's like coming
lower down the question now is where the
numbers go from here
were the lockdown measures effective in
much of the country people were told to
avoid family gatherings
multiple households getting together
over the holidays dr boucher says
patients don't admit it at first but
many of the coveted cases he's seeing
are coming
from family gatherings most people had
some kind of an exposure left or right
people believe that nobody's infected in
their family and that's unfortunately
not the case
now the full impact of christmas and new
years is still days away
in ontario the lockdown may have helped
plateau the numbers
and that plateau is very high but health
officials are watching to see what
happens
in one or two incubation periods i'm not
discouraged at this point i've seen it
flattening
but again the true story is going to
come out over the next week or so
one problem may be pandemic fatigue
people reaching a point where they let
their guard down
or break rules the way to combat that
health officials say
may be to focus on the fact there's now
a solution vaccines are being rolled out
across the country
i'm using that as an inspiration to to
get
just get people be a bit more patient
because going into 2021 and we're there
now
we're going to be seeing i think the
beginning of the end of the pandemic
if the numbers do jump in january
provincial governments will have to look
at ways of extending their lockdowns
or even expanding them closing more than
what's already shut down
they may also find it's not enough if
people aren't following the rules
anyway mike armstrong global news
montreal
breaking news out of ottawa tonight more
politicians not following the rules
two liberal mps have resigned from their
additional parliamentary and government
roles
after traveling over the holidays samir
zuberi
has stepped down from his parliamentary
committee role after visiting his wife's
ailing grandfather in delaware
he returned to canada on december 31st
kamal kara
has also stepped down from her role as
parliamentary secretary
she traveled to seattle to be with her
grieving family returning on new year's
eve
both failed to notify the chief
government whip before traveling abroad
the two join a growing list of
politicians in hot water after ignoring
public health advice to stay home
over the holidays nowhere is the
situation more dire than in some of
canada's long-term care homes in ontario
pressure mounts as coveted cases in
those facilities continues to rise
advocates and families are calling for
immediate action
and they're looking to other parts of
canada for solutions morgan campbell has
more
she dedicated 30 years of her life to
working
in long-term care and on new year's eve
sheila yaakov vision passed away
from kovitt 19. wanted to take res
take care of residents as she's the one
that
couldn't take care of herself the 60
year old worked at a windsor long-term
care home one of the more than 200 an
outbreak
across ontario which has sparked several
protests at homes
like tender care living center east of
toronto
60 residents have died from the novel
coronavirus
which has prompted an outcry from
families and advocates
demanding better conditions i didn't
realize how hard it was to communicate
with the government
or to get their response long-term care
critics say the province
isn't doing enough to help a sector that
is in
dire straits that is the result
of either a lack of prioritization
or a lack of understanding and it's hard
to imagine
how it could possibly be a lack of
understanding canada's national seniors
advocacy organization
says there are steps the province can
take now to curb the spread of covet-19
inside long-term care steps that include
a hiring and mass training blitz in
infection control
and ppe usage rapid response teams
similar to what new brunswick has done
that are trained in containment and
treatment of the virus
implement permanent infection and
control experts in homes
make rapid testing available to those
who live and work in long-term care
as evidence has shown that it is more
than 70 percent effective
and will help to screen out the virus
and
vaccinates there's been really good
steps done
by bc alberta new brunswick nova scotia
and quebec that we could have been
learning from to make sure that they
have these safeguards
in place ahead of what we knew and what
was well predicted to be a more
dangerous
second wave in a statement to global
news ontario's ministry of long-term
care
says it is working to address some of
the issues raised by advocates
in this story adding that it has
invested
1 billion dollars into long-term care
resources
morgan campbell global news toronto
british prime minister boris johnson is
warning that stricter lockdown
restrictions could be imposed
in england as new coven 19 variant
pushes infection rates to record levels
it may be that we need
to do things in the next few weeks
that will be tougher in in many parts of
the country i don't
i mean i'm fully fully reconciled to
that
the uk is in the midst of an acute
outbreak recording more than
fifty thousand new infections a day for
the sixth day in a row
emergency field hospitals built at the
start of the pandemic are being
reactivated to handle the expected surge
in new cases especially in london
most of england is already at the
highest tier four level
non-essential shops are closed and
people may only leave their homes for a
limited number of essential reasons
on monday residents across the uk will
get their first
shots of the oxford astrazeneca vaccine
germany's health ministers says that
country will likely need to
extend a national lockdown beyond
january 10th
german police chased people off the
slopes of a closed ski resort east of
dusseldorf today after hundreds flocked
there
germany imposed tougher social
restrictions before christmas
including closing restaurants and most
shops but infections continue to rise
and the death toll has climbed to close
to
1 000 some days the u.s
has reached another grim pandemic
milestone more than 350
000 americans have died from cobit 19.
and there's growing concern that number
will rise even further
as infections surge across the country
more than 20
million americans have tested positive
for covet 19.
in california a hospital is struggling
to deal with a major covet outbreak at
least
43 staff at a san jose medical center
have tested positive since last sunday
all of them work in the emergency
department the hospital is still
investigating the cause of the outbreak
but there are reports a
staff member wearing an air-powered
costume on christmas
may have contributed to the spread
former talk show host larry king is
reported to be in hospital with covet
19.
cnn says king has been hospitalized for
more than a week
the 87 year old has had medical issues
in recent years including heart attacks
diabetes and lung cancer he also lost
two of his children in 2020 within weeks
of each other
hospital protocols have kept king's
family members from visiting
an eyebrow raising recording has been
released today from the washington post
on it u.s president donald trump
apparently pressuring georgia's
secretary of state to overturn election
results in his state
and the recording comes before a
contentious week on capitol hill
11 republican senators plan to contest
the outcome of the u.s
presidential election when they count
the electoral votes that declared joe
biden president-elect
jennifer johnson reports please raise
your right hand
as members of congress are sworn into
office a bombshell recording from the
washington post
of u.s president donald trump apparently
pressuring georgia's secretary of state
brad raffensberger
to find enough votes to overturn his
defeat in that state
and there's nothing wrong with saying
that you know
that you've recalculated well mr
president the challenge that you have
is the data you have is wrong georgia
has counted its ballots three times each
time joe biden won
the recording comes as 11 gop senators
planned wednesday
to challenge the results of the
electoral college electing joe biden as
america's next president
we are not acting to thwart the
democratic process we're acting to
protect it we have tens of millions of
people that do not
view this election result is legitimate
the department of justice
fbi and several court rulings have found
no evidence of fraud in the election
even most republicans feel the senator's
challenge will fail
the reason it will go nowhere is because
there's been no evidence of widespread
fraud and that's been determined
by republican and democratic governors
across the country
and so the facts are the facts god bless
you we love you mr president
in the washington post recording the
president also claims his loss in
georgia will hurt two republican
candidates
in tuesday's runoff election which will
determine the balance of power in the
senate
if the two democrats win the house
senate and white house will all be
controlled by democrats
the first time in 11 years this is a
nail-biter
and my hope is that democrats will show
up and demonstrate that november is the
beginning of a pattern
president trump clearly still upset
about what happened in november
and president-elect biden planned to
campaign for their party's candidates in
georgia monday
meanwhile president trump's loyalists
planned to rally outside the white house
wednesday
to support senate republicans
challenging the election results
the president has tweeted he plans to
attend that event
colleen jennifer johnson in washington
thanks jennifer
coming up iran isn't ruling out further
revenge as the country marks the
anniversary of a u.s
assassination
[Music]
one year ago today a u.s drone strike
killed iranian general kasem solmani
and the world braced itself for the
fallout those fears were realized five
days later when ukraine international
airlines flight 752 was shot down by an
iranian missile killing 176 people
almost half of the victims were canadian
citizens or permanent residents
but as redmond shannon reports iran says
its revenge for sulmany's death
isn't over yet across iran the
government is making sure citizens
can't forget qasim sulaimani the
general's assassination at the hands of
a u.s
drone strike made him an instant martyr
always stood against isis says this
tehran woman
he was the only one who could do so this
weekend has
seen events across iran to mark the
anniversary of his death
protests too in iraq where he was killed
the number one terrorist anywhere in the
world
qasim salamani u.s president donald
trump ordered the strike after a series
of attacks on american bases in iraq
carried out by iranian-backed militias
those strikes continued after the
assassination
until five days later when two iranian
missiles hit ukraine international
airlines flight 752
176 civilians were killed including 55
canadian citizens
and 30 permanent residents iran first
denied involvement
eventually claiming it was human error
it says indictments are expected
this month it recently allocated 150 000
us dollars to each of the victims
families
canada says compensation should be
negotiated
and has rejected tehran's explanation
for the cause
this weekend the commander of iran's
revolutionary guard court
repeated a threat that iran is not done
with revenge
if you're sitting in tehran if you're
mulling over your options for revenge
the reality is that you have very
limited options iran's foreign minister
has also warned trump to
be careful of a trap before he leaves
office
claiming israel is plotting against u.s
targets in the region
to trick the u.s into war with iran it's
something israel has denied even if u.s
intervention is what they might want
trump has been renowned for
being averse to war drawing down troops
promising to bring the boys home
lambasting us interventions
in the past it's hard to imagine he
would throw all that away
just to spite by them president-elect
joe biden wants the us
back in the iran nuclear deal likely
subject to a renegotiation
trump pulled out of the plan in 2018
redmond shannon global news
london still ahead the
soulful investment that's keeping some
people a step ahead
just one of many videos by canadian
figure skater elij balday that's taking
social media by storm
the former competitive skater has gone
viral with videos of his high-flying
moves garnering
millions of views and shared by
celebrities like jada pinkett smith
and to think he almost didn't put on
skates in the first place
my mom was a figure skater um when she
was in russia
she had to stop skating at a very young
age but she had the passion for it um
and instilled it in me but i hated
skating when i started
um i tried to hide my skates and tell my
mom i lost my skates i tried to do
everything not to skate but she
was very committed balde went on to
compete internationally for team canada
now retired he says he wants his videos
to showcase
experimental styles beyond traditional
figure skating
hoping they inspire other skaters to do
the same
the pandemic has really kicked our
economy but
one industry hasn't missed a step in
fact it's growing by
leaps and bounds as brianna carsten
smith reports
collectors are proving sneakers aren't
just shoes
forget about coins stamps and even
vintage wines
the growing trend in collecting has a
whole lot of soul
kids treat them as stalks now with some
pairs of sneakers going for five figures
analysts are predicting the industry
could be worth more than
95 billion dollars by 2025
but for many collectors the obsession
actually starts with wanting to be
like mike
definitely nostalgia for me because you
were able to buy the shoes that you
watched michael jordan play in
back in in those days right jensen joe
and francisco rodas help run the
edmonton sneakerheads facebook group
each have almost 100 pairs they say a
recent documentary about the nba legend
has inspired more collectors and while
alberta's sneaker sales and resale
markets
don't fall into step with parts of the
u.s they are growing
i feel they're so it's smaller but i
feel like the community sense is
stronger
for 21 years foosh has been part of that
community
our main goal was to bring stuff to
edmonton that
nobody else was bringing in at one point
justin durr owned more than one
thousand pairs i was wearing artwork on
my feet
and the growing interest is keeping his
business alive
when so many others are struggling there
have been challenges
large conventions have been canceled and
usually when an exclusive and limited
edition shoe is released
people show up hours before the store
opens to get their foot
in the door having the lineups it allows
us to interact with the people that are
buying the shoes
and that's something that we're
passionate about obviously the shoes
themselves but it's really nice to talk
to somebody
about the product and maybe learn about
their history collecting
what got them into it still sneakerheads
are getting creative
rhodas customizes his sneakers now the
local teacher using it as a mix of an
art lesson
and history class they're always asking
me oh like when can you paint my shoes
next or
can you and i said well if you do really
good in the semester or in this grade
then maybe i might
uh we went work out something or just
something right to motivate them
for anyone wanting their own lesson in
collecting these experts say
just like wine vintage is better do your
research i mean there's so many
ways you can get to know the history
behind the designs
a hobby you can put your own stamp on
that can bring in some
serious coin how much do these go for
mac oh
too much probably
what brianna carson smith global news
and that is global national for this
sunday i'm colleen christie tonight's
your canada
is the picturesque mont santeller in
quebec if you'd like to share your
canada with us please email your photos
to viewers at globalnational.com
thanks for watching and have a good
night